ma io devo assolutamente adesso
esprimere le mie emozioni perché sto
male è perché sto male sto male davvero
sono una studiosa del dolore quindi
dovrei essere capace di parlare di
questo dolore perché sto male che questo
mi risuona perché è stato detto delle
cose dunque sto male per sia per la mia
paura del fallimento naturalmente che è
legata al mio desiderio di grande
successo ma al top come diceva la
speaker americana però tanta paura
ho tanta paura perché finalmente ed io
ci avevo provato era in america a
proporre la mia candidatura ma nessuno
aveva detto sì invece qua mi ritrovo
inaspettatamente qua ted quindi mi
tremano le gambe
avevo fino adesso un male allo stomaco
un pugno proprio guardavo la la valeria
14 anni sembrava molto più tranquilla di
me
eppure io ho fatto delle conferenze ma
non ce n'è questo è un opportunità di
successo è mica go sotto scusate
e farli meno male che fa ridere fa
ridere però meno male che fa ridere io
sono stata tossicodipendente dai 15 ai
20 anni ero in oman e per la precisione
quindi mi facevo le iniezioni in vena di
eroina e per procurarmi i soldi per
comprare l'eroina sono stata delinquente
e mi sono anche prostituita ecco io
volevo dire queste parole qui a ted
quando mio padre mi ha visto per strada
con un cliente mi ha fatto sapere che
non mi voleva più vedere se io non
smettevo di farmi e grazie a questo
ultimatum smisi entra in comunità
entra in comunità e mai più mi trovai
però tutti i problemi di autostima e di
autostima
ovviamente di vulnerabilità che mi
avevano portato all'eroina perché le
riina mi faceva sentire forte importante
perché perdevo la peggiore droga
tutti quei sentimenti comunque rimasero
ovviamente la comunità non era
sufficiente quindi iniziai una
psicoterapia 12 minuti e possibile
quindi rimasi noi iniziali una
psicoterapia che mi permise di capire
che io avevo bisogno di essere vista
questo è fantastico
avevo bisogno di essere vista
avevo bisogno di toccare il fondo avevo
bisogno di attirare l'attenzione dei
miei naturalmente ma anche di toccare il
fondo nel 1900
sapevo che mi sarei dimenticata di
mostrarvi le slide questa è l'epoca
delle droghe
l'infanzia la domanda bambino invisibile
ecco nel 1986 conobbi un fotografo
italiano milanese ci innamorammo e io mi
trasferii qui perché io sono spagnola
non l'ho detto
mi dicono forse se sono sarda ogni tanto
ma mi sento mezzo milanese 24 anni in
questa città
mio marito quello che fu mio marito non
più però è al fotografo e fotografo
giallo sto ammazzando e lui io lo
guardavo lavorare e lui fotografava le
persone e lui tirava fuori una forza e
un carisma nelle persone che di persona
non si vedeva
allora io affascinata da questo mezzo
pazzesco che la fotografia prima cosa
gira e l'obiettivo verso di me
il primissimo autoritratto 1988 fu
allora che avevo ricreato uno sguardo
quello sguardo profondo di cui avevo
bisogno e che prima io chiedevo agli
altri ma adesso primo passo verso
l'indipendenza meno da me lo faceva me
lo davo a me stessa e continuai a
fotografarmi dopo alcuni anni di
autoritratti comincia veramente a
fotografare gli altri perché gli
autoritratti mi permisero di aprirmi al
mondo è però continuavo fotografarmi e
nel frattempo fotografavo gli altri
facevo progetti divenne un artista
vincevo premi pubblicavo libri e facevo
le mostre finalmente avevo trovato il
mio strumento continuava fotografarmi
finché a un certo punto durante la
separazione da mio marito
provai di nuovo a fotografarmi e
scoprì che se io riuscivo a tirare fuori
la disperazione e il dolore lancinante
che sentivo nella foto mi passava subito
cinque minuti dopo cominciava a ballare
ea come che ero riuscita a passare
all'altro ed è per questo che ho parlato
del mio dolore
innanzitutto perché adesso non ce l'ho
più adesso il godere questo pubblico che
mi guarda
quindi l'ho fatto della fotografia la
mia medicina e poi anni dopo mia figlia
yassin per metà senegalese mi chiese se
poteva fare un autoritratto e scattò una
serie meravigliosa a tre anni e fu
allora che capii che quello che io stavo
facendo quella mia pratica artistica
poteva essere utili agli altri cominciai
a studiare il perché l'autoritratto
fosse così potente e cominciai a tenere
workshop di autoritratto costruì il mio
metodo che si chiama the self portrait
experience e cominciai a insegnarlo a
bambini il giro per il mondo adolescenti
adolescenti eterna adolescente che sono
nelle carceri questo san vittore
barcellona carcere tossicodipendente
nella inkoom una comunità per malati di
aids per malati terminali di aids
salvatore di pompei nei musei nelle
gallerie nelle università per terapeuti
per tutti i generi pubblici in modo che
le persone potessero usare il loro
dolore e metterlo nelle immagini
convertire dolore in arte e permettetemi
anche di dire merda in diamanti una
sorta di alchimia moderna
o cassetta o 6 minuti
una sorta di alchimia moderna perché in
realtà il nostro dolore e la nostra
merda è qualcosa che ha un potere
creativo e sociale enorme e questo
potere creativo sociale enorme vuol dire
che è fortemente condivisibile
ecco qua la prova ok se riusciamo a
farlo quindi ma perché l'autoritratto è
così potente
l'autoritratto non il self il self in
realtà immagine pubblica e creato perché
noi subito lo vediamo sulle reti sociali
invece l'autoritratto cioè quindi il
self ii più controllato perché tu
controlli l'immagine che tu vuoi dare al
mondo mentre invece l'autoritratto no
l'autoritratto e lasciare che il nostro
inconscio parli con linguaggio dell'arte
e dica quello che deve dire non importa
quello che dice se appari as appare un
mostro
ebbene è uscito il mostro finalmente
l'autoritratto quindi è la voce
dell'inconscio e quello che deve però
non ci etichetta non ci definisce perché
perché in realtà noi dobbiamo pensare a
due dimensioni
la dimensione conscia e che decidiamo
noi noi abbiamo deciso nella vita di
essere più o meno così di fare certe
cose non fare certe altre
e invece la dimensione inconscia ma
nella dimensione inconscia vi assicuro
noi tutti ognuno di noi alla potente il
potenziale di essere tutto e tutti da
madre teresa fino adolf hitler con tutta
la gamma in mezzo lì dentro il
potenziale c'è e il nostro inconscio ha
bisogno di esprimere regolarmente
qualsiasi cosa che ha bisogno di
esprimere quello che dobbiamo affrontare
oggi quindi usiamo l'autoritratto usiamo
queste immagini in cui noi non ci
riconosciamo che butteremmo invece di
buttarle lavoriamo su di esse per
stabilire un dialogo tra me e me
e così riuscire in qualche modo a
ritrovare in quelle immagini che rifiutò
non l'ho fatta più a ributtare immagini
e quella immagine che io rifiuto io
ritrovo i miei valori
ritrovo le mie emozioni profonde
ritrovo la mia infanzia la mia famiglia
ritrovo alle mie radici e ritrovo i miei
bisogni profondi che sono la base per
poter trovare la mia missione è per
poter realizzare i nostri sogni
queste foto che avete visto sono state
scattate durante i miei workshop di
autoritratto in queste foto
io lascio la persona da sola nello
studio don delle istruzioni
sull'espressione di emozioni me ne vado
la persona scattato alcune foto e poi le
mettiamo nel computer e io accompagno la
persona a guardare in profondità quelle
immagini e quello che succede è che in
queste foto viene fuori questo altro da
me ma solo guardandola anche solo cinque
minuti il fatto di vedere questi valori
questi bisogni e questo passato e questo
ovviamente questa persona in soli cinque
minuti riprende possesso di questo altro
da me e poi magari un'altra sessione un
altro da me e un altro da me è un'altra
cristina è un'altra cristina e così via
più forza più molteplicità perché in
realtà qual è il problema questa cosa fa
paura fa paura perché perché a scuola
nessuno ci ha insegnato che l'identità
non è fissa che l'identità e mutevole
che è molteplice che è sempre in
divenire a scuola mancava una materia
assolutamente indispensabile
questa il dolore le emozioni
l'interiorità umana
adesso guarderemo queste immagini questa
immagine concretamente e vedrete che nel
lato sinistro il lato sinistro e il lato
che corrisponde al lato destro del
cervello il lato nostro sinistro e il
lato delle emozioni della introspezione
il lato del passato e il lato della
vulnerabilità e il lato femminile
premetto tutti abbiamo lato maschile
femminile e qui avevamo visto
disperazione
avevamo visto rassegnazione avevamo
visto dolore lancinante ma anche una
reazione al dolore in un sessantesimo di
secondo che era questa foto il dolore ma
anche la reazione cioè un dire no non
tollererò mai più una decisione
ok invece l'altro lato vi giuro non è
photoshop e la stessa foto l'altro lato
invece è il lato dell'intelligenza e
lato della saggezza e il lato del
progetto è il lato della strategia per
raggiungere quel progetto è il lato del
futuro è il lato maschile
ripeto tutti abbiamo anche quel lato
usiamolo e quindi questa è la perfezione
umana
nell'altro lato vedevamo rassegnazione
ma in questo lato vedevamo l'opposto
vedevamo speranza vedevamo forza
vedevamo una vincita e quindi in realtà
noi siamo perfetti così siamo
l'unione di opposti perciò perciò quello
che io vi propongo è di dialogare con
queste immagini di pensare a voi stessi
alla vostra identità come qualcosa di
veramente molteplice e ricco che la
potenzialità ce l'avete tutti per fare
tutto dipende come si diceva prima da
quanta forza impegno da quanta
convinzione ci mettiamo dalla
possibilità o della capacità di lavorare
sulle nostre emozioni di comunicarle no
perché se noi usiamo l'arte che uno
strumento potente per tirare fuori
guardare creare questo dialogo potente
con noi stessi
diventeremo senz'altro più forti e più
saggi ma se in più noi vogliamo
comunicare questo al mondo come io oggi
ho fatto
qua allora acquisiamo il ruolo dell
artista che colui o colei che esprimono
e comunicano i bisogni profondi
dell'essere umano del presente e del
futuro grazie tempo zero